大家好,然后今天这次分享的主题是字节APM那些事儿。对,然后首先还是再次做一个做介绍,然后我是范雅东,然后目前是字节APM中台扣端的负责人,然后我的一个经历的话,只说最近的一次就在自己的这个经历吧,然后我是16年加入这一条动,从2017年底开始专注在APM这个方向,然后从0到1到n。
全程参与了字节APM中台的一个建设OK 这次这是这次分享的一个目录总共分为四个章节然后分别是APM到底需要做什么以及APM的难点有哪些然后以及字节APM团队的部分的工作成果展示然后最后一节是APM情形展望OK 首先我们进入第一个章节APM到底需要做什么首先APM这个缩写它的英文的全称是Application Performance
然后翻译过来质疑就是应用性能管理它可能比较抽象那应用性能管理到底是什么呢那可能对于大家来说对于我们普通联发的同学最常见的大家接触到的跟ATM相关的事情就是崩溃监控和启动优化崩溃监控这个很容易解释比如说我们APP新发了一个版本那么可能某些代码写了一个bug对吧那么在版本发布之后有一个新增的crash那可能
team leader或者是家国师会把一些问题的链接发给你告诉你一下单码有问题你需要去尽快的修复这个伙计这个这个几乎每个研发同学都经历过然后另外一个最常见的事情就是启动用话那随着app的开发迭代可能我们在启动阶段做的事情越来越多那在然然这个app的启动速度就会越来越慢那么某一天可能
某一天可能在我们发现应用的启动速度越来越慢之后然后非常影响用户体验那可能作为Team Leader或者加过时就会来找一些同学去做一些启动优化方面的事情OK 那么所以那么APM就只是这么简单吗我们只是把崩溃的监控优化以及启动的优化这两件事情做好这个APM这个方向这个领域就算做好了吗
那么答案应该是显然不是的这是源自于国外心理学的一个冰山理论什么意思呢就是很多事情如果我们只从表面来看的话就类似于冰山一样在水面之上我们只能看到它10%的部分可能隐藏在背后有90%的其实是更深层次的一些东西或者一些事情
对 然后这个一开始是应用在一个心理学的一个领域但是其实它在很多领域都会有一个应用场景那在APM领域其实同样也可以用这个理论也就是说我们前面看到的崩溃监控和启动优化只是APM领域的冰山一角可能甚至连10%都不到那么APM领域的它的一个全景图应该是什么样呢那么我们进入下一页的分享
OK 首先大家可以看到这张图最底下的紫色的部分我们其实这就是我们在软件研发的一个完整的生命周期包括研发测试集成灰度上限优化对这样一个不断迭代的一个流程OK 那我个人认为APM在研发阶段的各个环节都应该去发挥它比较重要的作用
首先在研发以及测试集成也就是说我们在挥度和上线之前的这个领域APM需要做的就是我们需要将我们代码的一些潜在的一些风险和问题提前的暴露或者说我们用专业的名词叫测试左移来去提前发现和规避更多的问题然后避免这些问题讨厌到线上那么在挥度和上线阶段我们应该去去做一些这边用黄色
之所以用黄色是因为在如果在灰度或者是线上阶段发现了一些问题那么理论上它可能影响比较严重是一些比较紧急的问题我们作为研发应该去更及时的去处理可能需要在小时级甚至分钟级别去去响应和解决这些问题那么这这这其中就包括各类性能或者是体验问题的稳定性问题的发现以及它原因的定位以及我们做一个线上的直损ok 那么因为客户都按代码它 native 代码它的一个
特性吧就有些代码可能你如果真的出问题很难通过很难做一些回滚那可能必须得新提交一个版本去彻底的修复那么最后就对应在优化环节这个阶段一个问题这里的一个过程ok 那我们再看一下在各个研发阶段我们APM到底具体需要做哪些事情呢首先比如说在研发阶段我们我们在研发在写代码的时候我们可以利用一些这个link工具比如说oclink
SwiftLint等来去确保我们新做了一些需求或者是新的一些代码改动是没有风险的没有一些性能或者稳定性问题的风险然后同时我们可以利用官方的一些工具比如说Chaco的自带的一些ZombieAson来检查一些一些也只正一些内存的踩踏内存的一出的等等潜在的一些稳定性问题另外我们可以用Instruments来跑一些比如说Time Profiler
比如说内存泄漏来避免一些问题遗漏到后续的阶段相当于我们在研发这个阶段需要我们研发的同学利用各种杠的工具来提前去发现和解决一些问题ok 那假如说这个阶段我们做的比较好了但其实理论上还是有很多问题可能是难免遗漏到后面的阶段对吧那这个时候我们就需要通过一些测试的手段来去
覆盖到各种GAM的问题的场景比如说我们可以做一些monkey的随机的稳定性测试做无论是安卓还是iOS都需要做一些设备的接种性测试然后我们需要做一个功能测试然后包括性能测试 单元测试 贸易测试等等那这些测试的手段有可能是人工去驱动也有可能通过一些自动化的方式去驱动对 这两手段都比较常见ok 那其实我们有各种GAM的测试手段那可能难免
还是没有办法在上线阶段提前发现100%的问题那一定有一些问题漏到了线上并且这些问题可能是突发的比如说后端我有一个上线对吧可能下发了一些不兼容的一些数据格式那就可能会如果客户端没有没有形容好的话就会造造上一些cross等问题那么在在灰度或者上线这个阶段我们需要
我们最需要做的就是在一个生产环境做一些应急的响应就是说我们有能力去快速的去发现和定位问题并且把它快速的去解决比如说我们iOS的稳定性包括CRAS、OM、CAS比如说我们的性能监控包括启动、磁盘、流量、电量、CPU、帧率、网络、图片等等然后当我们在问题发生的时候我们需要有一些报警的机制
不仅仅我人工可以去主动的去盯这些问题当他他个别的突发问题有一些量级的一些暴涨之后我可以去主动的铺使给我我们需要有问题的报警再比如说现在各个APP都都有一些组电话的研发模式那可能不同的同学他在说出的不同的模块我们怎么样把这些把一些报警后的问题我们快速的定位到他的原因对吧比如说可能是就是扣单代码写的问题还说一些后端的接口上线
导致的问题然后同时刚才提到在这个组电话研发模式下我们需要将这个问题快速的分发给对应模块需要负责解决解决这个问题的同学就是整体来说就是一个问题的报警 回应以及分发然后我们期望这个流程是比较全自动然后响应是比较迅速的OK 然后总有一些问题可能它我们比如说通过这个Crashdown战或者一些
通过其他的一些手段我们很难去直接定位到它的原因也就是说有一些一难问题那针对这些一难问题我们就需要借助到一些这个日治工具比如说我们需要研发在我们鞋带码的同时去郁埋一些在一些可能出问题可能有风险的一些地方郁埋一些日治埋点当线上一旦有一些突发了一难问题的时候我们可以借助一些远程调试的手段来远程的回捞这些日治去辅助我们开发者去分析比如说我们可以
回到一个用户或者是一群用户的日子然后排查一下他们的我们之前记录的这个日子中有没有一些可疑的一些问题然后他们这个日子有没有一些共性对来判断这个到底是什么原因造成了当前这个这个问题ok 那我再刚才也提到扣端他跟后后端或者是前端一个比较大的研发模式中比较大的一个差异的就是说我们内天的显带嘛
如果你没有任何的技术手段的话其实很难在线上直接去回滚或者是做一个代码修复的常见的一个传统的解决方案都是说我们需要做一个backfix然后提交一个新的版本但这样的话显然它的周期会比较长那么我们需要建设一些线上的动态的问题的降级兜底以及回滚的逻辑这里取一个例子比如说这个我们iOS中利用OC的round time的一些特性可以做一些安全气垫
之前网易的大白也有一些这个文章的分享再比如说安卓我们可以做一些热修复对吧直接下发一个派出包然后直接把这个问题去紧急的去修复那么我们期望这些动态的兜底或者止损的方案其实希望它能够越急时越好的这样我们可以在问题突发的现场在第一时间去紧急的去解决这个问题然后尽量的去挽回一些损失OK那么总有一些问题是我们
在线上可能没办法在第一时间能够处理掉了那么这个时候我们就需要通过扣端的迭代发板做一些backfix以及优化那么在这个阶段我们需要做的就是需要将一些稳定性问题或者性能问题做一个彻底的修复然后同时我们也需要假如说这个问题的影响面非常大非常严重的话我们需要做一个比较彻底的一个问题的复盘然后在复盘中我们产出一些改进的意见然后这些
改进了措施然后这些措施最终有没有落地我们需要做一个验收然后同时我们要检查我们前面的前面的阶段比如说我们的测试手段能不能有工具或者流程能够覆盖到这些问题然后避免它后面再次发生OK所以总而言之我个人认为APM应该去参与或者是渗透到我们研发流程的各个环节也需要扮演在各个环节中都需要扮演一个非常重要的作用
特别是在问题的删限阶段也就是测试左移这个阶段理论上这个观点在后面的PVD中也有提到就是理论上你发现一个问题的阶段越早那么你修复它的成本就越低它带来的影响就会越小所以我们从我们做APM理论上都是为了帮助开发者去发现和解决问题然后最终是为了这个用户的体验去负责OK那这也就分享到这里这是我自己的一个看法
也欢迎大家补充不一定是非常完整OK 讲完了APM到底需要做什么或者是APM的中数那我们再看下一个章节APM的难点有哪些首先这个问题可能如果大家做过启动优化或者是做过夸张式治理的话同学其实都会遇到这个问题是非常非常常见的我也很多次去听到别人吐槽这个问题然后我自己也经历过什么意思呢
就是说我们的我们的软件或者说我们的这个扣端的App我们在一个快速的迭代过程中对吧我们团队的规模在扩张我们业务在发展然后我们迭代的这个速度越来越快那么在这个过程中就会难免去引入各种各样的问题特别是你新写的代码新做的一些改动对吧那假如说ok某个版本可能可能Tim Lee的交给你一个任务让你优化一下启动时间那可能这个版本你确实优化了500毫秒那可能如果
后面你完全都不管的话只是说一锤子买完的话那可能下个版本这个数据会快速的裂画可能过了几个版本之后你的优化的一个成果已经完全被抵消了甚至你你当时已经优化了500毫秒那可能在过了几个版本之后它已经已经裂画了一秒对吧相当于把你的优化的成果完全抵消了甚至还出现了一个更进一步的裂画那么大家
自然而然就会有一个疑问就是我们怎么样在快速迭代的过程中去避免这种裂画首先这张图我先帮大家解读一下首先它的横坐标就是我们在软件研发的各个阶段比如说我们在编码在测试在一个集成在卡布就跟上一页PPT中我讲的研发的各个环节是相对应的
那纵轴就是一些事情发生的概率或者它的一个占底或者它一个权重首先我们看到蓝色的这个曲线是什么呢就是说在各个环境中bug引入的概率我们可以发现在85%的bug都是在这个需求研发人Hoding这个阶段去引入的这个其实也是符合大家直觉的因为bug肯定是我们研发同学写出来的对吧这个是很正常的一个现象然后我们再去看一个
据黄色的这个部分什么意思呢他就说我们在哪个阶段去发现这些Bug我们只是说一些主流的一些研发模式或者说一些大部分的一个通常常见的一个场景可能大部分的Bug我们是没发在研发同学在研发的这个阶段自主去发现的那可能我们总是要借助一些手段比如说我们的带原测试功能测试对吧一些集成测试
大家可以看到在测试这个阶段我们问题发现的概率是最大的那线上可能就是一些前面这个环节没有覆盖到的一些可能就遗漏到线上了对吧但是线上有可能它在整体的问题占领中并不是很大ok 那我们再看一下红色的曲线红色曲线什么意思呢就是说你在各个阶段你修复一个问题它的成本的一个差异举个例子可能这里的意思比如说
你在coding的阶段你在写代码的阶段如果你发现一个问题并且把它修复的话那么你的成本可能只有1分钟那么假如说这个问题最终逃异到测试或是线上阶段那它的成本会越来越高你的成本需要在测试阶段可以在研发阶段的40倍那么在最终生产环境中如果你想定位到一个问题并且彻底修复的话你的成本是研发阶段640倍
OK那么所以根据这个理论那么我们研发需要做的就是我们需要将测试左移我们需要在更早的阶段去理论上越早越好在更早的阶段去发现定位并且解决这些BugOK那么在说到一些具体措施呢我这边可以给几点比较有用的建议那如果你是在团队中你是Team Leader或者是架构师的一个角色那么你可以在团队中宣传贯车之中
大家在编码阶段的风险以及质量的意识就鼓励大家通过一些比如说刚才提到的一些插购的一些自带的一些工具然后通过instruments做一些这个性能以及稳定性方面的一些防烈化的一些自测然后通过我们的一些单元测试来保证这个或者是另一个工具比如说OseLintSwiftlin来保证我们写的代码尽量是少去引入一些风险和问题
OK那么可能大家会有一个又会有其他的问题比如说我依靠人去做这个事情呢他很难去持续或者说业务业务压力太大那很难有人力去长期的投入到这个性能我内心自策的这个方向那怎么办呢OK那么针对这个问题我们可以看第二点就是我们可以想办法通过一些自动化的流程和机制去驱动测试什么意思呢比如说就就比如说自己前段时间开源的那个fastput
我们可以依赖FastBot去做一些随机的一些文明测试业界也有一些方案去可以做一些性能方面的防烈化测试对 总而言之就是我们为了降低人工参与的成本解放大家的经历和时间提升整体的一个迭代的效率我们可以通过更多的一个自动化的流程和机车来驱动测试来发现通过自动化的形式去发现更多的烈化问题
OK 然后第三点我认为也是非常重要然后也是非常现实的一个问题就是如果说大家真的想把防练化这个事情做得非常体质也就是说英文前面提到的两个点虽然它都可以做都可以落地但是还是有一些简单的风险比如说我就是测试出一些问题研发说我没有经历去改或者说我认为这个问题并不重要那可能这个问题就真的遗漏到线上了对吧
可能英文它需要人去主动的参与主动的去做优化主动的去做一些做bugfix那么它难免会有一些遗漏对吧如果你完全不想如果你想尽量少的问题去遗漏到后面的环节的话那么我个人认为还是需要在我们CICD的流程中去设置一些卡口来去规范准准出通过这样的形式去拦戒电话什么意思呢 举个例子比如说我们在
你研发核码的时候我们在踢MR的时候我们去跑一下比如说getlab的一个pipeline那么这个pipeline是什么呢我们可以检查一下你代码变更的我们用另一个工具对吧用一些静态检查工具去跑一下你的新提交代码你新的改动有没有风险如果我们认为风险很大的话能不能是不是就阻止它这一次核码也就是说通过这样一个形式去强迫它在核码码的时候就把我们已经检测到了一些代码的风险给
修复掉那么准准那么这是一个准入的环节那么准出是什么呢假如说OK我们现在代码已经合入了那么那么在这个时候假如说这一个版本已经封版了我们我们可以针对所有的这个需求改动我们做一次整体的性能以及防炼化的一个一个一个做一个防炼化的一个流程OK我们假如说检测到这个这个这个版本新合入的一些需求和代码假如说某一次定位到
某一个MR它的弹码有风险引入了一些crush一些卡磁对吧或者一些内存的问题那么我们可以就强迫它在把这个问题作为一个卡口这些问题如果不解决的话那么我们没办法进入到一个挥动或者是一个提省阶段通过这样一个形式我们去强制性的提醒我们的研发同学去主动的去关注并且修复一些组册性的问题那么这样的话我更认为是最有效的
也是最彻底的ok那么难点二的话这个问题相信大家也很容易遇到就是ok我们现在现现现有的一些这个APM的一些平台比如说这个八格雷呃天云firebase对吧等等那么我们在定位呃有些问题可能我们研发看一眼看一眼调研站我们就可以很容易一的定位到定位到一些问题但是有还是有相当一部分数量的问题它是属于一个遗难问题那么当我们研发同学看到这样一个调研站的时候
比如说这个这一届PPT中的一个调用帐大家可以看到它是一个传系统的一个调用帐那么一般同学在看到这样问题的时候我们是很难有思路的对吧会有点不知所措我不知道该怎么下手去解决这个问题OK所以可能就卡住了然后这个问题那有可能它在以后的版本它量积越来越大但是有可能我们的研发是束手无策的OK那么
这个这APVT是什么呢就是Ls.JSUM一个日子JSUM就是说我们在App发生了OM crash的时候会在设备中会留下一个系统日子它会告诉你哪个应用崩溃了然后它崩溃的时候内存的占用是多少OK 那看完这个日子你肯定会想OK 我知道我这个App因为内存占用过高倍系统强制散退了那么这个内存到底搭在哪里呢
对吧 我怎么要去优化呢我代码几百我这个APP这个工程量非常大有几百万行的代码我怎么知道到底是哪里引入的问题呢这个问题点 列画点到底在哪里呢我怎么要去修呢是不是也是完全没有任何的思路OK 所以我们在做APM的时候我们的一线同学会经常会遇到这样一些问题就是总是有一些遗难的问题我们是没有办法定位它的原因的
因为你没有办法定位到它的根本原因所以也很难的去做一个问题的修复OK那么这里我可以给出一些建议就针对这种遗难问题我们怎么样能定位到它的根本原因呢首先第一点我觉得就是因为我们做技术嘛这些遗难问题肯定是需要大家去深入一些底层的原理去做一些技术深度上的一些研究和应用
对吧 那么我们需要去传言这些问题的一些底层原理然后去建设一些系统性的归因工具举一个例子 比如说我们怎么让定位OM问题OM它无外乎就是某些场景下我们内存占用过高了对吧那么假如说我们能够知道通过哪个调用站分分的内存占用比较高是不是有可能对我们解决问题比较有帮助那么基于这个思路 那微信
QPU团队以及微信团队分别开原了OM Detector以及Metrix然后通过这样基于这个SDK以及我们后台的这些能力我们有能力做到当发生OM的时候我们有能力定位到说哪些调用站它分配的内存比较大OK那么这是一个思路然后另外一个思路就是说我们能不能分析出当前的这个假如说当前这个App内存占有已经很高了对吧我们假如说到了
那么我们能不能定位除这一季的内存节点分别有什么比如说有哪些类它的每个类它有多少对象对吧以及这些内存对象内存节点之间的一个互相的引用关系是什么那么基于这样一个思路字节字眼这个线上的Memograph这样一个工具在后面PET中也会比较详细的提一下大家可以认为如果你用到插库的Memograph的话相当于我们把这个东西做到了线上OK 说这两个工具的意思就是说假如说你去
比较深入的去思考这个问题然后去钻到一些底层的原理那么你应该去想办法去建设一些系统性的一个归因工具假如说我前面提到这两种的思路如果你都做了那我认为其实不存在说哪个OM类型的问题我们定位不到OK 另外一个问题就是说我们需要想办法将问题暴露在第一线场什么意思呢
我们发现Crash类有相当一部分的遗难问题它有一个特点就是说问题的崩溃的场景和它问题发生的第一现场它并不一致举个例子比如说A业务我在对上分配一块内存但是它有一个越界的一个行为OK 因为内存它是一个全局共享的那可能你A业务分配一块内存你越界然后去写入到了B业务的一个内存的区域里但这个时候它不会Crash
但有可能在毕业物它可能一个OC对象已经完全你把它写坏了对吧我在调用这个对象的一些方法的时候它就会发生crash那么其实这个最终崩溃调用战发生在毕业物中那有可能毕业物它只是一个受害者它不是问题的产生问题的一个根本原因对吧那么针对这类问题我们能不能想办法加问题暴露在第一现场假如说在A业物它这个内存约定的时候我们直接就crash对吧
我们抓到当时的一个电话站那么我相信这个问题解决起来它的难度会低很多那么也是基于这个思路那么插库的自带的就是Ason就是Adress Satellizer是专门解决出来的问题的但是Ason它有一个非常明显的问题就是它仅适用于我们线下的开发者的一个debug阶段它需要带把插庄然后同时它的性能是比较差的我们很难去做到做在线上那么针对这个痛点我们字节建设了一个线上的Ason的一个
一个能力我们有能力将一些内存量的问题将问题包在第一现场然后也是基于这个工具我们内部最近排查到了非常多的一些历史的一些遗留的一些遗难问题其中就包括今日头条可能已经持续好几年的一个隐藏的问题然后最近已经这个问题量级已经上升到全版本的这个套比然后也是通过我们现在就去解决了
然后还有一点就是有可能有一些一难问题比如说它并不是一个稳定性问题它不是一个夸出问题但是作为APM领域来讲我们也是需要建设一些工具和平台来辅助用户去很方便的去排查一些问题比如说一些UI错乱或者说比如说抖音视频播放的时候有一些花屏或者说
串音等这样一些要类的问题那么针对这样一些应当的问题我们认为一个比较好的手段就是大家需要重视一个日日工具日日工具是刚才在最早的时候在介绍APM全景图的时候也有提到过我们需要在研发的时候在一些可能出问题的一些环节或者流程中去主动的去记一些这个事件和买点这样在发生问题的时候我们能够拿到一些现场的信息对吧比如说可能
后端的一些接口有没有爆出它的一些自断与我们最初约定的一些类型是不是一致等等总之你一切觉得可能有风险的一些地方都可以去买一些点加一些日子那业界也有些开源的方案比如说微信的XLOG对吧但XLOG只是可以让我们在本地写入一些日子但是它没有去不涉及一些回捞就是如何去回捞如何去分析这些日子
是需要我们开发者自己去考虑的那么基于这些日子我们可以就会发现一个用户或者是一群用户的可能能发现出一些他们的共性能够发现这类问题的一些蛛丝马迹也就是说虽然是有日子工具但是也需要大家研发在日常的开发中我们对于一些有风险的环境我们研发需要有意识的主动去添加一些买点日子OK然后问题三相信大家也
基本上每个应用每个APP都会遇到就是当我们在线上有一些问题突然爆发的时候我们怎么样去第一时间止损呢刚才也提到扣端的这个研发模式它本身就有一个局限就是说我们的network代码如果是传统的方案如果不通过砂板提升是很难在第一时间在现场去解决它的这里举一个例子比如说在应该是二一二一年的时候Facebook SDK有一个
因为他们后端上线下发了一些不兼容的一些数据类型有一个大面积的崩溃特别是海外的APP基本上一些主流的APP全都中招了那么针对这样一种一类突发的问题我们怎么样在第一时间去做一些都底然后去把损失降到最低呢OK 那么我这边给出了一些建议就是我们APP可能会接入很多一些第三方的 SDK那么假如说这个 SDK 是必远的话
因为它必远所以说你对它没有任何的掌控力你也可能很难第一时间去操作或者是影响它那么针对这种必远的 SDK或者说我们自身App有一些有风险的一些改动比如说我们做一些底层的一些重构这样你认为一些有风险的一些 SDK接入或者是改动我们都需要增加一个云控的开关就方面说我们在一些紧急的场景下我们顶哥说我们通过后端的一些操作紧急的把这个开关给吓掉
那么最坏的一个结果就可能就说这个SBK它不启动了对吧它的一些能力可能就失效了那么总比我们用户在启动刚启动就遇到一些crash或者卡死这种问题还是要相对来说好一些对吧相当于我们做了一些兜底和直损另外就是我们在问题爆发的时候假如说它不是说我们客户端本身的问题或者说它可以通过一些后端的上限或者是回滚来做一些
来做一些止损那我们需要在问题爆发的时候去排查这个时间点或者这个时间段有没有一些后端服务或者是AB实验的一些变更就是我们能不能通过后端的一些回滚的操作来逼时间去降低这个问题的影响OK再一个比较重要的点就是我们能不能去在端上探索一些像iOS安全起点安卓的热修复以及可能很多的大App都会做的一个事情就是启动保护
就比如说我们假如说我们发现这个某个用户在启动阶段连续的crash或者连续的cast的时候那么我们能不能提醒用户去清理一些缓存对然后可能能够把那个crash给跳过让这个用户能够继续正常使用这是我认为三个比较官验的点吧然后第三个章节就是说我们聊一下字节APM团队我们部分的一个工作成果
因为我们在我们团队内部这个方向已经做了已经四年多了相对来说我们有一些不错的一些工作成果然后这里跟大家分享一下然后可能很多能力我们也已经在火山引擎做做了面向外部开发者的一个输出比如说这里一个工具是我们做了一个我们的面向研发的一个个人的这个性能分析工作台然后简单来讲它这个工具有点
大家可以简单的认为它就是一个面向开发者然后同时它的使用门槛更低然后更方便的一个instruments它相比instruments它的优势是什么呢首先就是这个工具的使用成本非常低门槛非常低只要我们的设备通过有线或者无线的手段形式连接到我们的mic上然后我们就可以针对我们的app去做一个性能的分析以及调试
而且我们被分析的这个App我们没有任何限制你可以是一个debug的debug版本的一个安装包也可以是release版本的安装包甚至是一些进品的安装包都可以我们不而且我们也不要求你植入任何的sdk甚至如果你有那个问题发生在现场的话我们你完全都不用重启这个App就可以去直接定位到一些现场问题然后它可以去监控到App的各个的性能指标比如说CPU内存
磁盘流量 电量 帧率等等然后如果你有App的一个符号表的话你还可以直接去定位到比如说一些启动当中的一些或者说在主场景中的一些漫寒树如果你发现卡顿的话你可以定位到一些漫寒树这个图中大家可以看到我们通过火焰图的这样一个形式非常直观的能看到哪个水平块越宽那么它就是可能会更耗时
那么除了方法耗时之外我们还可以与此同时我们也可以看到各个县城的一个县城的状态它是在运行的状态还是在被一个组色的状态然后同时我们可以看到各个县城的一个CPU的一个占用通过这个工具大家可以非常简单快速地去定位到一些性能的裂花问题而且使用门槛偏向地OK那么这是我们字节APM平台的一个火山引擎的突闭版本就是APM Plus
那么这个功能是什么呢就是我刚才跟大家提到的我们在线上分析内存占用的这个Memograph那么它的基本的原理以及使用的一个形式跟那个插口的Memograph是有点类似的就是我们可以帮助你识别出当前的内存中哪些节点它的内存占用最多比如说大家可以看到这里VM 引力加IO这个对象它有47个
然后这47个对象占了内存的500多兆那么它显然不是一个非常合理的占用那么我们可以通过分析它的一个影关系我们可以看到最终我们定位到这是飞书的一个例子我们在最终定位到是一个飞书的Rust SDK的一个回调然后去引用了这些图片那么我们就能定位到一些可能图片异常使用的一些场景对吧可能我们换成的
策略不合理或者说我们使用了一些同时解码的一些大图等等通过这样一个手段我们相当于有在线上分析内存占用以及做一个归因的一个比较强大的一个能力那么这个能力现在已经上线到自己APM的火山引擎图笔版本就是APM PlusOK那么这个工具是什么呢就说它是我们解决
一些inacros类问题的一个大杀器我们把它叫做coudump,coudump是什么呢?coudump实际上就是一个文件格式然后大家可以认为coudump就是相当于我们在app崩溃的现场我们把所有的一个内存的一个状态给coudump下来比如说当时的一个计存器站内存以及一些脏的一些堆内存那么基于内存的信息基于这个文件格式我们可以利用
LLDB的一個原生的一個調適能力去做到一個現場清晰的還原以及調適就像大家在崩潰的那一刻打了一個斷點一樣我們可以通過LVM的一些指令去分析這個當時App的一些現場的一個狀態比如說我們可以分析一些計算器比如說這裡接頭中的我們可以分析X0計算器它的一個Nation地址是什麼在一個我們可以分析假說你是一個也只人類型的話我們可以分析當前的
崩潰的这个地址它被哪些现成或者哪些对象去持有OK 那么基于这个工具我们在字节内部发现了一个也是一个成天老bug吧那这个bug在各个的产品线在头条在抖音在西瓜火山都有那么最终修复了这个问题之后我们相当于这个top1的crush达到一个完全的修复那么各个产品线的一个崩溃率
整个字节系App的崩溃力最终降低了8%就是我们基于靠达我们这个工具来解决了OK 那么最后我们做一个ATM的前景掌握首先 第一个趋势就是刚才跟大家已经分享过了我认为就是测试左移现在已经逐步成为一个业界共识了我们作为开发者需要将更多的问题暴露在更早的阶段来降低这个bug的影响面以及它的修复成本那么自动化测试的这个覆盖面
一些大原测试一些性能测试 自动化功能测试我内心测试我们需要通过自动化测试的形式去持续的覆盖到更多的场景那么另外一个点就是说我们在线上突发问题之后我们有没有一些自动化的流程比如说之前也提到了一些问题的报警 归因然后自动化的分发然后我们能不能自动的去定位到一些比如说后端的一些
接口的一些上限或者變更然後能夠做到自動的一些壟斷和回滾相當於我們可以在第一時間去做到一個兜底和降低這個問題的影響面然後另外一個點是我發現就是我們做客戶端跟後端研發模式是一個比較大的差異然後後端同學可能他會有一個工作習慣就是他會有一個報表去實時的去看一些指標或者是一些數據然後
這已經成為後端同學一個研發模式的一個日常但是客戶端同學我們在面對一些問題或者一些監控的時候可能大家整體來說還是偏被動那麼我思考過其中的原因可能就是因為我們因為作為客戶端來說它的代碼最終上線的一個或者部署的一個形式它畢竟是一個單體我們沒有做一些場景化或者犀利度的拆分它跟後端這種微服務的分布式的研發模式有所不一樣
那么可能我作为一个某个模块或者说某个页面的负责的同学你让我去实时的去看整个App的一个数据对我来说可能我觉得干扰会比较多所以说我觉得一个趋势就是我们的监控数据可以以场景甚至页面的力度去做一个聚合然后同时我们的一些监控的指标和数据甚至可以跟后端服务的一些监控去做一个打通培养起我们扣端同学这种一瞻式盯盘的一个习惯
就更主动更及时的去发现一些潜在问题那么最后一个是我的一个理想就是可能在自己我们的专业篇目也发现很多问题其实它的原因是类似的我们期望一些遗难问题的一些解决经验或者说它的思路可以在我们整个集团内生在整个业界去做一些互通然后提升我们整个行业软件研发的一个质量和水平
PVT的分享环节可能就到这然后不知道是不是有点超时了然后后面的时间我们先交给主持人移动